haha the Joe Rogan experience oh it's
the best driving I mean before the
pandemic when there was still traffic
driving around at 4:00 a.m. you're awake
mmm you're half asleep also I think it's
easier to work out that early cuz you're
but whatever part of your is this that
[ __ ] is just like weak gotta be careful
lifting weights in the morning you
really want to warm up because you can
injure yourself a little easier
sometimes you know that yeah cuz you
just sleep it all night you're kind of
stiff you want to warm everything up get
everything going they say that people
lifting weights it's not the best idea
to lift like your personal record
deadlifts and [ __ ] like that first thing
in the morning it's just yeah you got to
heat your body up it makes sense your
body's more heated up by the end of the
day by the end of the day you lose
you've been walking around doing stuff
looking forward to you workout getting
pumped and then you can go in there and
workout I used to love jiu-jitsu class
at 8:30 p.m. for me that was perfect
because jiu-jitsu is like eight at 8:30
it's like man I got plenty energy I've
eaten all day
you know it's like I'm not tired yet
like going to bed tired but you know cuz
back then I was going to bed it like two
o'clock the morning every every night
anyway but it was like 8:30 was perfect
done by 10:00 I'd hit the comedy store
be on stage at 11 that's crazy I don't
like working out at night
I loved it loved it it's great because
you're you have energy but you but it's
easy to do because you wake up at noon
you know and just [ __ ] stumble out of
bed do whatever [ __ ] you have to do
that day if I my day off from you know
doing stand-up at night yeah it's easy
you just eat and hang out and then
eventually work out but if you get up in
the morning get a little bit of a
victory yeah a little bit of a victor
just having accomplished that thing
you've gotten up and then next thing you
know you doing chin-ups or maybe you're
doing chin-ups you know doing shows well
I could do like to do them done due to
what I was what more what it would be is
like me sitting on those nice couches at
Equinox writing because like I said I
don't work out yeah I would
procrastinate and that's what I realized
it's like I do my best writing at the
gym that's hilarious so do you bring a
little notebook well yeah I just started
bringing my spirit there to write and
then I would just sit and write and
we're hold spend so much time writing
cuz if that part of you that doesn't
want to work out well
rather right it's like when you have to
write you find yourself cleaning mm-hmm
it's that you know you can like sort of
convert your procrastination into
something positive
yeah yeah that's interesting then I
would go work out you know but I would
like I was so when I was doing that man
I was getting the best ideas I was just
running on the treadmill stoned if you
know 5:30 or whenever the [ __ ] gym
open and you're I was listening to this
like I started listening to that was
when I was listening at Goggins so I'll
be blasted listening to Goggins running
on the [ __ ] treadmill like yeah [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna do ultra [ __ ] marathon
how about that I'm never gonna do ultra
marathon you listen to him too and he's
aware that people like me are gonna be
hypnotized by him because he's like
don't do what I'm doing you can kill
yourself just exploding to it how many
people do you think have collapsed at
the gym cuz it David Goggins I bet like
what 30,000 people
yeah for sure this is probably a lot of
blown out knees out there whoa not
[ __ ] up Beck's gone biceps that guy
will run with his foot falling off the
step book is really good what's that
it's called can't hurt me yeah Jesus
like it's amazing he likes shows his
calf muscle background swig that guy
could like I get like if that guy wanted
to like burrow into an elephant he could
he's a good dude - I like hanging out
with him he might be I've hung out with
him a few times
gone to dinner a few times yeah yeah
yeah he went to the fights a couple
times he's a good dude he's a fun guy
meme I enjoy him me and my friend think
he's enlightened he's something he's
something special there's there's a
switch that that guy has that we all
wish we had well he can he can power
through but also he's a beacon of
inspiration like for other people when
David Goggins does the [ __ ] that he does
and and when he has those speeches while
he's running you know like it's like
someone's talking it was like 104
degrees outside and he goes why you
running because I'll tell you why I'm
running because you're not [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's why I'm running and you know that
he's out there just I mean he's he's
constantly doing it like he's constantly
pushing himself that's what I love me
that's this he's like a servant in that
way he's a servant he's a servant to the
world he's not just like he's really
giving people because like he's put he
post pictures of himself when he was
like sort of fat all the time and I'm
like yeah I'm showing people like look
this is the possibility at any moment
you can do this at any moment and I love
that because I do I know when I see him
like he's like running through glass
he's running like you know he's like
running through like swarms of
mosquitoes and malarial swamps just to
show people look it doesn't the part of
you that's telling you that you can't do
this because of X in your environment is
probably wrong not all the time but for
sure man a lot of the time wrong a lot
of time and not for a lot of us that's
like so powerful like I've met of all
the self-help books I've listened to I
listened to my audible that's the best
one by four hands down that's the best
one man but because it's real it's not
from a guy who really hasn't done
anything that's trying to get you
motivated to go out there and conquer in
life it's from a guy who's actually done
some really [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and it's
telling you that you can do it too and
that he used to be weak yeah he's doing
something right now because Cameron
Haynes son Truitt is trying to break
Goggins 24-hour chin-up record so
Goggins was at he was like what can I
think it's like Cameron Haynes
Instagram page see if he let put the
video on his Instagram page but he was
at some ungodly number of chin-ups what
when they were making the video he's
right that break that yeah he's like
I've been doing chin-ups for nine hours
straight like fifteen hundred chin-ups
or something stupid crazy yeah and he
still had all those hours to go so I
think it might even be like a two-day
thing I don't know how many days are
supposed to be doing this but it's um
you have it in there with Goggins is
there a video of Goggins doing chin-ups
I mean the story that hope I'm not
releasing any information that shouldn't
get out
is this live again dope out there yeah I
can't find it yeah whatever anyway you
want to see the show he's doing I would
love to see your show
so anyway shout out to try it out shout
out to Truitt good luck freeway shout
out to Goggins I hope I hope they dig
battle
[Applause]